so listen this is not new for you the
last time you did a live TV musical you
kind of stole the show so how is it to
be back I'm excited to be back
especially to be back with my Ames will
do much you know how did you you know
you just finished how to get back into
it did you instantly want to come back
yeah I mean I can't the day after we
aired so I was very excited to come back
I said yes immediately and I just I love
this show I love the message of the show
anything you learnt from that live show
once one-and-done experience that you'll
take or give to the newbies on set new
together and it's gonna be exciting I'm
really excited to share this this show
with ever this new version and you know
she is like my favorite she's my
favorite I'm a big RuPaul's Drag Race
follower and I really love you so you
better take care you'll cover me right
yes listen you're no stranger to
performing and this character feels like
it's right out of your PlayBook but this
has got to be exciting this is sort of
your first huge thing that you've done
since being on that show my major first
big role to the small screen so I'm
definitely taking on a lot but I'm so
excited especially because it's like
because mama girl I'm always like hey
let's just get a bigger stage and we're
gonna bring it I'm new to this and I get
to work with people like Brannon who are
professionals award-winning and yes and
it's such such a blessing to be here
because I'm getting to meet all the cast
and you for the first time you heard it
all from RuPaul about the announcement
that you're gonna be in it does he know
Moroni I think she does know I was on
set with her the other day but there was
no exchange yeah but everyone on his
team congratulating really oh I love
that okay now they are musicals and then
there are musicals like rent that are
juggernauts and so beloved and
are so important to so many people do
you feel the pressure that this is one
of those shows this is an institution
this is a lifestyle this is you know 365
days no day but today you know just to
feel the pressure
I would journalist I'm giving you the
facts there's some pressure on this one
I don't feel pressure yeah if anything
I'm just excited girl give me the
microphone let me do it mm-hmm put push
play on the cameras girl I'm ready I
just feel like if I put the pressure on
me yeah I get emotionally in my head and
I get worked up but if I just take it on
like okay just another day yeah another
dollar hey girl
and and if I just really focus and take
it on yeah I think I just deliver my
gift but when I overwork it that's when
I just get in my head
so no pressure yet okay but we haven't
started rehearsals have you spoken to
any of the original cast members or
anyone that has been in the cast in the
past you know Vanessa's been Mimi before
any I know you know all those people I
do know that man I've done the show
before myself yes I did but I did sit
down and I had a conversation with
myself wait to be talked over a couple
things we got sidetracked to tell but we
came back to the topic but I mean I
didn't a lot of the cast members reached
out to me whom I'm working before and
they just say congratulations and they
were so excited that Brent family is
getting to be a part of this new version
now were you Tom yes
so you've played this this is easy for
you and you're like I know this but it's
a little different I'm generally
familiar with the place okay so a little
different is there anyone that you would
love to see cameo or from the original
cast kind of pop in and like maybe one
smaller role to kind of I guess I feel
about that what would it take
bring it behind over here take big me to
come up on stage he need to throw in a
tattered jacket and he need to stumble
across there just one time just one time
I don't have me a piece I love that is
there a favorite song
scene in the musical that you're the
most excited to perform that you think
is it's gonna be the moment no of course
not today for you that's the one I live
for any angel bet yeah I'm not gonna lie
my dream role would be to be me me and
you out tonight yeah I'm secretly I'm
Tomas understand we won't tell her now
okay angel the two times I've seen the
show on Broadway and at the Hollywood
Bowl there's a lot of like down to the
knee and then hang out you know like are
you ready for working with the
choreographer is amazing okay and yeah
I'm just gonna oil it up these knees huh
and learning how to jump on tables and
full heels working on my drumming last
girl let's do this I'm so excited this
last question this this musical really
at his baseline is about friends who
become family why do you think that's
such an important thing for viewers and
people to see during the holiday season
I think particularly at this time with a
lot of the distress and the conflict we
see I think it's so important to see a
group of friends that really learn and
discover that that you know love
transforms anything law transforms
disease the disease of prejudice disease
itself transforms the disease of poverty
is in a phobia patriarchy like our
message is to measure your life and love
the love you give and the love you allow
yourself to receive and so I just think
it's so important that we share it right
now and I'm so excited for you all to
see it definitely I feel also as
somebody as part of the LGBTQ community
a lot of people in the LGBTQ community
are not accepted by their actual family
so you kind of have to go off and choose
your own family and be part of a tribe
and find your own people and I think
that's so important because there's a
lot of people out there that don't get
the acceptance from their blood family
but you can always go out there and find
a friend or somebody that you can really
know that can you can really lean on and
say you know what I might not have the
my fat my real family backing
but you are now my chosen family
[Music]